look up and notice I'm romcom romantic
comedy guy but I did notice well I want
to do some other things no no no no you
can't do that and I noticed I was like
oh the industry and the public are
nothing other than romcom shirtless
count on the beach I'm not doing those
anymore 20 months nothing an offer comes
in for a script at 8 million bucks I
said no thank you they come back at 10
million I say no thank you they come
back at 12.5 million uh
small they come back at 14.5 million I
say let me read that script again
I read the script Gaby guess what now it
was the exact same words as the original
offer but I read that script again and
it was better
written better 145 and you did it but I
said no you said no said no was that
movie made wait real quick for fun I
love this was that movie made no no